Cuando pienso en los sueños,
como muchos de Uds.,
pienso en esta imagen.
Tenía ocho años cuando vi a Neil Armstrong
bajar del módulo lunar a la superficie de la luna.
Nunca había visto algo así antes
y nunca he visto nada igual desde entonces.
Llegamos a la luna por una sencilla razón:
John Kennedy nos puso una fecha límite.
Sin esa fecha límite,
todavía estaríamos pensándolo.
Leonard Bernstein dijo que se requieren dos cosas para un gran logro:
un plan y falta de tiempo.
(Risas)
Los plazos y los compromisos
son las lecciones clave aprendidas gracias a la misión Apollo
que dan sentido a la frase "sueño lunar".
El mundo necesita desesperadamente líderes políticos
dispuestos a proponer metas audaces
para llevar a cabo una vez más sueños osados como el Apollo.
Cuando pienso en los sueños,
pienso en las drag queens de Los Ángeles y Stonewall
y en millones de otras personas que arriesgaron todo
por salir del armario cuando eso era realmente muy peligroso,
por esto, esta imagen de la Casa Blanca iluminada con los colores del arcoíris,
sí...
(Aplausos)
celebra el derecho a casarse de los gays y lesbianas de EE.UU.
Una imagen que ni en mis fantasías más alocadas podría haber imaginado
a los 18 años
cuando me di cuenta de que era gay
y me sentí ajeno a mi país
y a mis sueños por esa razón.
Pienso en esta imagen de mi familia
que nunca soñé que podría tener...
(Aplausos)
y en nuestros hijos mostrando ese titular
con un veredicto del Tribunal Supremo que nunca soñé que vería impreso.
Necesitamos más del valor de las drag queens y los astronautas.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Pero quiero hablar de la necesidad de soñar en más de una dimensión
porque hubo algo sobre la misión Apollo que no supe cuando tenía 8 años,
y también algo acerca de cómo emergen los colores del arcoíris.
De los 30 astronautas de los programas iniciales Mercury, Gemini y Apollo,
solo siete salvaron sus matrimonios.
Esas imágenes emblemáticas de astronautas rebotando en la luna
eclipsan el alcoholismo y la depresión que experimentaron en la Tierra.
Thomas Merton, el monje trapense,
preguntó en la época del Apollo:
"¿Qué podemos ganar con ir a la luna
si ni siquiera podemos cruzar el abismo que nos separa de nosotros mismos?"
Y ¿qué podemos ganar con el derecho a casarnos
si no podemos superar la amargura y la distancia emocional
que tan a menudo nos separa de nuestro amor?
Y no solo en el matrimonio.
He visto la lucha más dañina, destructiva, y trágica
en el activismo LGBT, del SIDA,
del cáncer de mama y del activismo sin fines de lucro,
todo en nombre del amor.
Thomas Merton también escribió sobre las guerras entre santos
y que había una forma generalizada de violencia contemporánea
a la que el idealista sucumbe más fácilmente:
el activismo y el exceso de trabajo.
"El frenesí de nuestro activismo neutraliza nuestro trabajo por la paz.
Destruye nuestra propia capacidad interior para la paz".
A menudo, nuestros sueños se vuelven obsesiones ancladas en un futuro
que destruyen nuestra capacidad de vivir el presente.
Nuestros sueños de una vida mejor para un futuro de la humanidad,
u otra humanidad en otro lugar,
nos aleja de los hermosos seres humanos
que tenemos a nuestro lado en este preciso momento.
Y argumentamos que es el precio del progreso.
Uno puede ir a la luna
o tener una vida familiar equilibrada.
Y no concebimos que se puede soñar en ambas dimensiones al mismo tiempo.
Y rara vez superamos la ambición de la estabilidad familiar
cuando se trata de nuestra vida emocional.
Por eso, nuestra tecnología para comunicamos
se ha vuelto vertical,
mientras que nuestra capacidad para escuchar y entendernos
simplemente ha desaparecido.
Nuestro acceso a la información está por las nubes,
y nuestro acceso a la alegría ha caído en picada.
Pero esta idea de que nuestro presente y futuro son mutuamente excluyentes,
de que para alcanzar nuestro potencial
tenemos que sacrificar nuestro profundo potencial de ser,
de que la cantidad de transistores puede duplicarse y aumentar,
pero que nuestra capacidad de compasión y humanidad y serenidad y amor
de alguna manera está limitada,
es una opción equivocada y sofocante.
Pero no estoy sugiriendo simplemente la idea aburrida
de lograr un mayor equilibrio entre la vida laboral y familiar.
¿De qué sirve que pase más tiempo con mis hijos en casa
si mi mente está siempre en otra parte mientras estoy con ellos?
Ni siquiera hablo de atención plena.
La atención plena, de repente, es una herramienta para mejorar la productividad.
(Risas)
¿Cierto?
Hablo de soñar tan audazmente en la dimensión de nuestro ser
como lo hacemos en la industria y la tecnología.
Hablo de una autenticidad audaz
que nos permita llorar juntos;
una humildad heroica que nos permita quitarnos las máscaras y ser reales.
Es nuestra incapacidad de estar en la presencia del otro,
nuestro miedo a llorar juntos que da lugar a tantos problemas
que estamos frenéticamente tratando de resolver, en primer lugar,
del bloqueo en el Congreso a la inhumanidad económica.
(Aplausos)
Hablo de lo que Jonas Salk denominó Época B,
una nueva época en la que estamos
muy entusiasmados y sentimos curiosidad científica
por el desarrollo de nuestra humanidad
como por el desarrollo de nuestra tecnología.
No debemos rehuir esta oportunidad
simplemente porque de hecho no la entendemos.
Hubo un tiempo en el que no entendíamos el espacio.
O porque estamos más acostumbrados a la tecnología y el activismo.
Esa es la definición misma de estar atrapado en una zona de confort.
Ahora estamos muy cómodos imaginando logros tecnológicos inimaginables.
En el año 2016, es la dimensión de nuestro propio ser
la que reclama su parte de nuestra imaginación.
Ahora, estamos aquí para soñar,
pero quizá, si somos honestos al respecto,
cada uno puede perseguir su propio sueño.
Ya saben, mientras buscamos a aquellos que pueden ayudarnos con nuestro sueño,
a veces lo que no vemos es la humanidad del otro.
No puedo perder tiempo contigo ahora. Tengo una idea para salvar el mundo.
¿Cierto?
(Risas)
Hace años, en otra época, tenía esta hermosa empresa
que organizaba viajes largos para una participación ciudadana heroica.
Y teníamos este mantra:
"Humano. Amable. Sé ambos."
Animábamos a la gente a experimentar una bondad inusitada.
Del tipo "Ayuden a todos a montar sus tiendas de campaña".
Y había montones de tiendas.
(Risas)
"Compren helados para todos".
"Ayuden a la gente a inflar neumáticos
aunque llegaran tarde para la cena".
Y la gente hizo lo que pedimos
tanto que si uno pinchaba en la marcha del SIDA,
tenía problemas porque había mucha gente que ofrecía ayuda.
Durante unos días, para decenas de miles de personas,
creamos estos mundos
que todos decían que era la forma en que deseaban
que el mundo fuera siempre.
¿Y si experimentáramos creando ese tipo de mundo
en los próximos días?
Y si en vez de preguntar: "¿A qué te dedicas?"
preguntamos: "¿Cuáles son tus sueños?"
O: "¿Cuáles son tus sueños incumplidos?"
Ya saben, TED: aTEnder los sueños de los Demás.
(Aplausos)
Quizá sea: "Quiero permanecer sobrio",
o "Quiero construir una casa en un árbol con mi hijo".
Ya saben, en vez de buscar a la persona que todos quieren conocer,
acérquense a la persona que está sola
y pregúntenle si quiere tomar una taza de café.
Creo que a lo que más tememos
es perder la oportunidad de alcanzar nuestro verdadero potencial,
ese sueño con el que nacemos;
y a morir sin siquiera tener la oportunidad de cumplirlo.
Imaginen vivir en un mundo
en el que reconociéramos mutuamente ese profundo miedo existencial
y nos amáramos unos a otros fervientemente
porque sabríamos que ser humanos implica vivir con ese temor.
Ha llegado el momento de soñar en varias dimensiones al mismo tiempo.
En algún lugar que trasciende todas las cosas maravillosas
que podemos, debemos y vamos a hacer
existe el mundo de los seres increíbles que podríamos ser.
Ha llegado el momento de explorar esa dimensión
y hacer evidente que, de hecho, tenemos sueños allí, también.
Si la luna pudiera soñar,
creo que soñaría eso para nosotros.
Es un honor estar con Uds.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)